here are four strategies for getting the
nourishment you need without getting
eaten by a crocodile in Africa our first
contestant is the yellow-billed stork
that bill isn't just a deadly accurate
way to fish once the stork catches the
fish it uses the bill to juggle the fish
so the fish will relax those spiny
appendages making for a much more
enjoyable meal the Crocs don't bother
the storks the storks are too fast and
probably not a no too bony I mean not
enough meat on those bones but here we
have a heron
with a tasty seafood buffet in its beak
and it's being stalked by this crocodile
or its meal is the Heron is near the
water to wet the fish so it will slide
down its throat but croc is waiting for
just the right moment to scoop the Heron
into dropping the fish so the croc can
gobble it up himself in the end the
Heron makes it all too easy
how about that let's move on to African
bee-eaters these birds also have to
figure out how to stay fed and hydrated
without becoming croc chow here's the
croc getting in a position like an
outfielder waiting for a flyball the
thirsty Birds hover trying to find the
one square inch of water that's safe got
close but no cigar
here's the peanut gallery waiting for
the next match and here is the next
match oh so close but I guess you'd call
that the crocodile equivalent of an air
ball finally a bird called a qui Liam
these huge flocks seem to interest our
crocodile quite a bit
does the croc wanna me lurk just a
thrill
now looks like he wants a little of both
the qui Lea's take a victory lap around
the lake and decide to give the croc one
more chance
Crocs typically hunt using the element
of surprise they do not chase their prey
he begs one one out of grunt five
thousand still the crock showed the
world that still got lightning reflexes
and an overbite men won't quit